♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT, HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES WE HAVE BEEN SO
DEEPLY ENGROSSED IN HER OWN
DEBATES OVER WHETHER MEN SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO COMPETE ON GIRL'S
SWIM TEAMS OR WHETHER IT'S
IMMORAL TO CARRY OUR GROCERIES
IN A PLASTIC BAG THAT WE HAVE
MISSED THE FACT THE GOVERNMENT
OF CHINA HAS BEEN BUSY WITH ITS
OWN AGENDA, TAKING OVER THE
WORLD.
IN THE SPACE OF JUST 15 YEARS,
THE CHINESE HAVE SUCCEEDED IN ME
COLONIZING THE ENTIRE CONTINENT
OF AFRICA.
DIDN'T THINK THAT COULD HAPPEN?
IT IS HAPPENING.
IN AFRICA, CHINA NOW CALLS THE
SHOTS, IT TAKES THE NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR ITSELF, PERIOD.
AS OF TONIGHT THERE IS ONLY ONE
REMAINING AFRICAN COUNTRY THAT
DARES TO RECOGNIZE TAIWAN AND IT
HAPPENS TO BE AMONG THE SMALLEST
COUNTRIES IN AFRICA, SWAZILAND.
EVERYONE ELSE ON THE CONTINENT
OBEYS BEIJING.
HOW CAN THIS BE HAPPENING?
ISN'T COLONIALISM RACIST AND
BAD?
YES, IT IS AND NO ONE IS WORSE
AND MORE RACIST THAN THE
CHINESE.
GO ON CHINESE SOCIAL MEDIA
SOMETIME AND SEE HOW THEY
DESCRIBE THE AFRICANS THEY'VE
SUBJUGATED, IT'S HORRIFYING.
WHY ISN'T "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
WRITING STORIES ABOUT ANY OF
THIS?
YOU KNOW WHY.
BECAUSE "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
ON CHINA'S SIDE, THAT'S WHY THEY
ALL BUT IGNORE THE BRUTAL
CHINESE COLONIZATION OF
LATIN AMERICA WHICH IS ALSO IN
FULL SWING RIGHT NOW.
COLONIALISM VIOLATES EVERYTHING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ONCE CLAIM
TO BELIEVE IN BUT THAT'S OKAY
BECAUSE I NEVER REALLY BELIEVED
ANY OF IT ANYWAY, IT WAS ALWAYS
ABOUT POWER.
WE CAME TO BRAZIL THIS WEEK TO
SEE FOR OURSELVES WITH THE
CHINESE ARE DOING TO
LATIN AMERICA, WE MADE A
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT IT.
BRAZIL HAD THE LAST PRO-AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT IN LATIN AMERICA COME
OUR SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT ALLY
IN THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE.
ALLOWING BRAZIL TO BECOME A
COLONY OF CHINA WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT BLOW TO US AND
POTENTIALLY A SERIOUS MILITARY
THREAT.
>> PRESIDENT BOLSONARO DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN SOCIAL DISTANCING,
DOESN'T WANT LOCKDOWNS, MUCH
MORE EXTREME THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> BRAZIL FAR RIGHT NATIONAL
PRESIDENT GYRE BOLSONARO SPOKE
AT AN EVENT IN DALLAS, THESE TWO
MEN AND FELLOW TRAVELERS
REPRESENT THE GLOWING STOMACH
GROWING GLOBAL THREAT TO THE
IDEAS OF LIBERALISM.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHOSE RESEARCH CONSISTS OF
3 MINUTES ON WIKIPEDIA ON THE
WEIGHT OF THE STUDIO.
HE'S A RACIST -- OF COURSE HE
IS, HE DOESN'T WANT LOCKDOWNS,
THERE'S YOUR PROOF.
IT'S YOUR LAST CLIP FROM FAREED
ZAKARIA THAT EXPLAINS WHY THEY
ARE SO MAD AT BOLSONARO.
HE REPRESENTS A GLOWING GLOBAL
THREAT TO THE IDEAS OF
LIBERALISM.
MEANING NEOLIBERALISM, MEANING
GLOBALISM.
THAT IS TRUE.
HE'S NO JUSTIN TRUDEAU, IS NOT A
LOW IQ FASCISTS WHO WOULD BE
WORKING AS AN INSTAGRAM
INFLUENCE OR IF HE DIDN'T HAVE
HIS OWN ARMY.
HE'S NOT THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE WHO SHUTS DOWN
TELEVISION STATIONS WHO DARE TO
CRITICIZE HIM AND ARMS.
IN CONVENTIONAL TERMS, BOLSONARO
IS LIBERAL, HE HAS DONE NOTHING
TO STOP CIVIL LIBERTIES IN
BRAZIL.
AT THE SAME TIME HE IS A
NATIONALIST COME HE CARES ABOUT
HIS COUNTRY, HE RESISTS CHINA.
THEREFORE HE MUST BE STOPPED.
GEORGE SOROS HATES HIM, SO DOES
JILL BIDEN.
HE'S NOT WITH THE PROGRAM.
NATURALLY WE WANTED TO MEET HIM,
YESTERDAY WE DID, WE SAT WITH
HIM FOR MORE THAN AN HOUR AND
THE FIRST THING WE LEARNED WAS
THE LEFT IN BRAZIL HATES HIM
VERY MUCH, THEY TRY TO KILL HIM
WHEN HE FIRST RAN FOR PRESIDENT
FOUR YEARS AGO WITH VERY LITTLE
MONEY AND THE BACKING OF NO
PARTY, HE CAME OUT OF NOWHERE TO
GET 57 MILLION VOTES.
HE ALMOST DIDN'T SURVIVE TO BE
ELECTED.
HE WAS STABBED BY A LEFTIST
ALMOST TO DEATH AT A RALLY AT
WHICH POINT THE LEFT FUNDED
LAWYERS TO COME IN AND RESCUE
HIS ATTEMPTED MURDERER.
AN AMAZING STORY THAT HASN'T
GOTTEN A TON OF COVERAGE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE'S AN AUTHORITARIAN SAYS
MSNBC.
WE ASKED HIM ABOUT THE STABBING
IN OUR CONVERSATION WE ASKED HIM
ABOUT HIS CHRISTIAN FAITH WHICH
IS ON DISPLAY, SOMETHING ELSE
THAT TRIGGERS THEM.
WE ASKED ABOUT THE SUPREME
COURT'S STANCE ON ABORTION, H